immer wieder zunehmende gewalt gegen
polizisten deshalb rufen wir heute auch
zum großen bild innenminister gipfel und
dazu begrüße ich auch ganz herzlich
unseren bild vize paul ronzheimer und
zugeschaltet der innenminister von
bayern joachim herrmann der
innenminister von nordrhein-westfalen
herbert reul für sachsen roland wöller
und aus dem saarland klaus bouillon
schön dass sie alle bei uns sind ja uns
alle beschäftigt dieser mord an den
beiden polizisten herr herrmann als sie
davon gehört haben sie als erfahrener
innenminister wie alle hier in der runde
was ist ihnen da durch den kopf gegangen
entsetzen
unglaublich fürchterlich und ich kann
nur sagen das hört man sofort wie das
natürlich hier auch alle
polizeibeamtinnen und -beamten
beispielsweise in bayern ja gerade in
deutschland natürlich sofort massiv
bewegte und letztendlich auch nach dem
was wir inzwischen wissen unbegreiflich
einfach völlig irre und wir können nur
versuchen jetzt bestmöglich die
hinterbliebenen der opfer zu
unterstützen zu begleiten und es ist
wichtig dass jetzt alle polizisten in
deutschland unsere solidarität spüren
wie genau sollte diese solidarität
aussehen her wie kann man sozusagen den
polizistinnen und polizisten in
deutschland jetzt auch zeigen dass
deutschland hinter ihnen steht
ja in denen man das erstens nicht nur
sagt sondern auch tut die haben wir noch
sagen westfalen zum beispiel nachdem wir
die regierung von rot-grün abgelöst
haben erstmal dafür gesorgt dass
polizisten auch sicher ausgestattet
werden dass sie wenn sie ihnen einsätze
gehen auch genug helme haben
schutzwesten haben waffen haben dass die
autos in ordnung sind das heißt um
quatschen reichlich die polizisten
wollen aussehen dass wir für sie was tun
und ich glaube das ist das erste und das
zweite ist haltung zeigen für respekt
sorgen dafür sorgen dass in der
gesellschaft überhaupt mal wieder
ernsthaft darüber nacht wird wie wir
miteinander umgehen und das bedeutet
eben denjenigen die da ganz besonders in
der ersten reihe stehen polizisten den
rücken stärken er pro jahr wenn man sich
dann schaut nun aber wie die
öffentlichkeit damit umgeht es gibt
trauer es gibt große berichterstattung
bei uns bei bild bei vielen anderen
medien aber man hat nicht das gefühl
dass öffentlich wirklich teilgenommen
wird dass es zum beispiel
demonstrationen gebe oder öffentliches
trauern warum sind wir da so
zurückhaltend
ich denke was die öffentliche trauer
angeht haben wir die trauerbeflaggung
angeordnet die politik und viele
menschen haben der polizei ihren respekt
gezollt aber was ich vermisse dass die
schweigende mehrheit sich deutlicher
positioniert wir sehen an den beispiel
und der montagsspaziergänge wie die
respektlosigkeit zunimmt das was die
polizisten die es gut meinen die auch
teilweise diese menschen schützen sich
anhören müssen spaltet mittlerweile
jeder beschreibung
ich wünsche ihm eigentlich eine bewegung
der preisen bevölkerung der mehrheit die
deutlich macht dass wir diese polizei
brauchen wenn das nicht passiert bin ich
etwas sage aber herr weiler glauben sie
nicht dass das vielleicht auch aufgabe
der politik sein müsste da ein bisschen
mehr entgegen zu wirken und auch in der
öffentlichkeit vielleicht ein etwas
anderes bild von den beamten zu zeigen
das ist richtig ich war fassungslos wenn
zwei junge menschen die sich für unsere
sicherheit einsetzen getötet werden
ausüben ihres berufes
wir haben auch in sachsen
trauerbeflaggung angeordnet um
öffentlich ein zeichen zu setzen ich
habe auch viele gefragt warum eigentlich
es ist in der tat so dass die
öffentlichkeit es wenig auch angeht aber
richtig ist wir müssen nicht nur die uns
polizisten gut ausrüsten das tun wir
auch wenn man sagt die body kämen extra
eingeführt das sorgt für mehr schutz wir
haben auch als innenminister gemeinsam
die damalige bundesregierung
aufgefordert den bundestag aufgefordert
das strafrecht zu verschärfen
das ist auch geschehen wir haben also
eine freiheitsstrafe bis zu fünf jahre
aber das genügt nicht ich glaube müssen
darüber reden dass es nicht mit
geldstrafen alleine abgegeben werden
kann also mindeststrafen müssten erhöht
werden auf mindestens ein halbes jahr
haft geld allein reicht nicht ich glaube
das ist ein ganz wichtiges zeichen dass
müssen in den nächsten tagen und monaten
mit der bundesregierung gemeinsam
angehen hermann geld allein reicht nicht
gleichzeitig geht es aber auch darum wie
die politik über polizisten spricht bei
bild wir haben sie eingeladen wir lassen
immer wieder polizisten zu wort kommen
aber wenn wir uns anschauen hermann wie
zb die innenministerin hier in berlin
also die bundesinnenminister nancy
faeser ganz am anfang erst mal gesagt
hat ja jetzt wird es diese studie über
vermeintlichen rechtsradikalismus bei
polizisten auch geben die immer
diskutiert worden ist was macht das mit
den polizisten
ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig dass wir
in der tat auch die politische führung
klar hinter der polizei steht man muss
ja deutlich unterscheiden das ist in
kusel war ein brutaler mord von
kriminellen wilderern und darauf steht
ohnehin
lebenslange freiheitsstrafe das ist der
ein die eine sache die andere sache die
mehr insgesamt so schrecklich dieser
mord ist er mehr sorgen bereitet ist die
zunehmende gewalt gegen
polizeibeamtinnen und beamte im alltag
auch zum beispiel am rande von anti
corona
demonstration man darf demonstrieren gar
keine frage aber das dann aus solchen
situationen heraus dann wirklich immer
wieder gegen polizeibeamte vorgegangen
wird dass sie tätlich angegriffen werden
dass sie beleidigt werden dass sie
bespuckt werden das ist heute das ist
gestern auch in den social media zum
beispiel aus der querdenker szene heraus
gerade zur freude gab da wurden gab es
der
veröffentlichungen in den social media
in dem sinne ja gut zwei weniger und
ähnliches ja unglaublich das ist das was
wir hier in teilen der bevölkerung ist
nicht nur eine kleine minderheit aber
immerhin spüren das ist unerträglich und
wenn in der tat zum beispiel im jahre 20
und 21 die spd-vorsitzende es kann sich
an der diskussion über rassismus in der
polizei beteiligte ich kann nie
bestreiten dass es unter tausenden von
polizisten eben auch mal ein schwarzes
schaf gibt aber den eindruck erweckt als
ob das ein größeres gesamtproblem in der
polizei wäre dann ist das einfach falsch
und mit solchen politischen äußerungen
trägt man dazu bei dass es eine
verunglimpfung auch polizeiarbeit kippte
das ist unerträglich dass darf in der
politischen führung unseres land ist
nicht passieren sonst braucht man sich
nicht zu wundern dass da mancher bürger
auch meint er könne nach belieben mit
irgendwelchen unsinn um sich schmeißen
und deshalb sage ich da klar ja dort wo
es schwarze schafe gibt muss dagegen
vorgegangen werden aber insgesamt macht
unsere polizei ist super arbeit das sind
die männer und frauen die jeden tag und
jede nacht ihren kopf für unsere
sicherheit hinhalten und da haben die
auch verdammt noch mal die volle
rückendeckung der politischen führung
haben also allen parteien zu haben hat
jetzt hatte ich aber ganz konkret nach
nancy faeser gefragt der
bundesinnenministerium und wie sie ihren
job beurteilt diese
ich hoffe sehr dass frau fehse auch sich
hier klar zu den leistungen und zur
polizei bekennt sie hat sich gestern
auch natürlich klar zu diesem
schrecken über diesen mord bekannte aber
ich kann nur sagen ja diese ganze
diskussion eben immer wieder wir müssen
uns stärker mit dem rechtsextremismus in
der polizei beschäftigen das ist einfach
unfug weil das nicht typisch ist noch
einmal mit einzelfällen müssen wir uns
beschäftigen
aber ich glaube inzwischen davon geht
jedenfalls aus ist klar es gibt das noch
von horst seehofer in auftrag gegebene
gutachten das erstellt wird und dann
sehen wir uns das mal an ich sehe nicht
nicht den geringsten anlass dass der
jetzt irgendwelche anderen studien
wieder neuen auftrag gegeben werden
müssten gehen sie damit bei herrn
herrmann oder glauben sie nicht auch
dass man versuchen muss vielleicht doch
irgendwie auch durch gewisse studien
egal was dabei rauskommt eben das
vertrauen der bevölkerung
zurückzugewinnen eben durch transparenz
transparenz ja aber nicht durch studien
studien ist was für hochschulen wir
können wir noch ein paar machen von mir
aus aber ich glaube viel drängender ist
die frage das wirklich praktisches
handeln und eigenes tun und durch
handeln und vorbild der politik dafür
sorgen dass wir diejenigen die für uns
den kopf hinhalten nicht nur ernst nimmt
sondern ihnen den rücken stärken wissen
sie ich glaube manchmal die polizisten
sind diejenigen die in ganz besonderem
maße für unseren staat eintreten das was
wir von allen bürgern ständig erwarten
da gibt es tolle vorträge zu wie man zum
start stehen soll die machen es jeden
tag jeden tag und am ende sogar setzen
die ihr leben ein und ich finde da es
mehr zu erwarten als irgendein netten
spruch oder die für betroffenheit weil
jetzt meiner wenn jetzt mal zwei
gestorben sind das ist zu wenig wir
haben im letzten jahr ich glaube über
9.000 angriff auf polizisten bei uns gab
immer nur ein beispiel und wir haben
deswegen beschlossen wir machen bei uns
eine respekt kampagne also eine kampagne
eine bewegung in der bevölkerung für
polizisten für rettungskräfte für
feuerwehrleute wo wir sagen wir als
bevölkerung wir als menschen stehen auf
sonnen ihnen respekt stärken in die
rücken und die politik kann das
praktisch beweisen nehmen sie mal moment
die berliner politik als ich angefangen
habe hatten wir hier eine kennzeichnungs
gesetz für polizisten die polizisten
sollten alle eine marke drauf kriegen
damit jeder ihnen anzeigen kann ja das
war ein misstrauensvotum gegen und
polizei zusammen abgeschafft und das
erste was dieser in berlin vor haben
diese neue komische ampel die haben
jetzt vor kennzeichen für
bundespolizisten zu machen herzlichen
glückwunsch fängt der ganze kram schon
wieder vorne an das ist keine hilfe für
polizei sondern das misstrauen gegenüber
polizei und zu empfinden die das auch
wenn die abends unterwegs sind und
deswegen glaube ich ist das die
wichtigste aufgabe politik muss als
erstes mal stehen und dann müssen wir
uns richtig anstrengen damit die
gesellschaft das geht weit über das
polizeiteam hinaus wieder mal respekt
für einander empfinden dass wir diese
respektlosigkeit im umgang untereinander
die sind diese hass und hetze im netz
aber auch auf der straße dass das jahr
beenden kann man es ja nicht mit einem
schlag aber dass man da mal aufmerksam
macht und wirbt dafür dass man anständig
miteinander wiederum geht von mir aus
altmodische tugenden wieder nach vorne
bringt herr müller was wir über den fall
wissen den mord an den beiden polizisten
ist dass die beiden täter wilderer waren
viele menschen gruselt ist jetzt und sie
sagen was steckt da hinter diesem
phänomen was wissen sie über die frage
von wilderern wie gefährlich kann das
für weitere polizisten für menschen in
deutschland werden also wir haben ja
eine regelung die ist auch in unserem
bundesland nicht anders als in
deutschland
starke zunahme von gewalt gegen
polizisten
die letzten zehn jahre hatten wir eine
steigerung über 50 prozent
2011 2000
straftaten jetzt sind das über 3000
sprach taten und was die beiden
polizisten betrifft das sind ja nicht
nur junge menschen familien mütter
sondern das ist ein angriff auf unsere
gesellschaft
angriff auf diejenigen die uns schützen
und deswegen ist die gesellschaft
natürlich auch aufgerufen hier dem etwas
entgegen zu setzen und ihre frage zu
beantworten wir haben eine starke
zunahme von waffenbesitz und wir haben
auch eine starke zunahme von waffen zb
in besitz von reichs bürgern von selbst
verwaltern von extremisten und hier
haben wir auch sagen versucht
verschärfung herbeizuführen waffen
gehören nicht in die hände von
extremisten weiß nicht ob die wilderer
schon vorher straffällig geworden sind
oder auffällig geworden sind das muss
jetzt müssen die
strafermittlungsbehörden beurteilen aber
klar ist wer von vornherein nicht gbr
bietet
ordnungsgemäß damit umzugehen deshalb
lassen wir das vom verfassungsschutz
überprüfen der darf erst gar nicht in
den besitz einer waffe kommen ich glaube
das ist der richtige weg um ja auch mehr
sicherheit für die polizei herbei zu
führen wie sieht es in ihrem bundesland
aus machen sie sich sorgen was die
wilderer angeht wie sehr gruselt sie
dass dieser fall
nach unseren erkenntnissen ist das mehr
oder weniger ein einzelfall dieser mann
hat das über jahre offensichtlich
betrieben war auch schon
polizeibekannt es kam schon mehrere
vorfälle er war nicht mehr im besitz
einer waffenerlaubnis all diese dinge
haben wir mittlerweile zusammengetragen
ich denke es war mehr ein einzelfall die
wilderei ist ein produkt aus dem
saarland stattfinden
das war unser großes land mit vielleicht
nur eines sagen was ja was die kollegen
gesagt haben ich denke die iren die die
entscheidungen gefallen sind in den
letzten jahren müssen verstärkt werden
es reicht nicht mehr aus bei dieser
häufigkeit von gewalttätigkeiten von
bleiben in anspruch und diffamierungen
gegenüber der polizeien einsetzen wir
sollten uns darüber im klaren sein dass
wir vielleicht gemeinsam beantragen dass
die mindeststrafe halbes jahr ist damit
deutliche zeichen gesetzt werden wir
reden jetzt schon über 67 jahre über die
verschärfung das reich meines erachtens
wie die kollegen sagen dann nicht aus
dies wäre ein wichtiges zeichen der
politik zugunsten unserer polizei es
sind gespannt ob sie das dann auch
tatsächlich alle umsetzen wir danken
ihnen sehr dass sie sich die zeit
genommen haben für unseren großen bild
innenminister gipfel paul danke auch an
dicht